Here we are at one of the country's most interesting zoos.
Here we find the wolf in his natural setting.
Next, a pack of camels.
A North American greyhound.
And here, two bucks.
And five scents.
And here, two friendly Elks.
Hello, Bill.
No zoo would be complete without a monkey cage.
Hey sister!
Can't you read?
Mother Nature's own weatherman: the little groundhog and his shadow.
Over here, we find...
Hey son, hey!
Hey, don't annoy that lion!
It's dangerous.
Can't you read that sign?
You'd better take my advice and leave him alone.
Shame, shame.
You're a bad boy.
The skunk cage is always a center of interest.
Well, we're lucky.
It's feeding time for the giraffe.
Listen now, fella.
This is the second time I've had to speak to you.
Leave that lion alone.
I'm warning you.
I'm a bad boy.
And here we come to a family of white rabbits.
Of course, you all know how fast they multiply.
Now over here in the bird house, we find the wise old owl.
Who?
You.
Me?
Yes.
An interesting bird is the South African talking parrot.
Polly want a cracker?
I said, Polly want a cracker?
Nah, give me a short beer.